mais le professeur olivier
lyon-caen pour son livre
priorité cerveau
et le sociologue louis chauvel
pour son livre le destin des
générations
elle
lilian compan jours nouveau
merci d'être là
vous êtes le professeur de
médecine à un spécialiste
donne de rose biologie % et de
neurologie tout simplement
pour ces versions du cerveau
en e2 exercer donc à la pitié
salpêtrière et vous coordonnez
en france
l'état des
10 des traitements
en est de la connaissance sur
eux les maladies neurologiques
le froid qui touche au système
nerveux central
% vous avez présidé à
l'élaboration de de livres le
premier s'intitule priorité
cerveau avec le docteur etienne
hirsch qui est un livre
collectif
qui fait le point sur l'état
des connaissances et des
traitements
sur les maladies du cerveau
et un autre style le cerveau
pour les nuls
evitech effet lorsqu il est bon
de domme d'un accès évidemment
plus fun plus facile et qui
expliquent la encore à la fois
les connaissances que l'on peut
avoir du cerveau aujourd'hui
et puis les traitements des
différentes maladies qui
peuvent survenir
en e avant de
peut-être de dire un mot un peu
plus avant de ses livres
peut-être un monde
la place au fond de la france
dans le temps c'est un domaine
qui était essentielle
et qui est tout ce qui touche au
cerveau pourquoi parce que
tout cela accompagné le le
vieillissement de nos
populations
et donc on voit surgir des
pathologies
les nouvelles ou en tout cas si
elles ne sont pas nouvelles sont
plus importantes que celles des
populations touchées
mais en même temps les progrès
sont là
et donc comment voilà comment
évaluer pour 100 e l'intensité
là la qualité de ses progrès
notre propre place mais que sa
recherche française
dans ce secteur
dans ce secteur willy geiger
j'ai envie de vous dire
jean-marie colombani cueff
le 21e siècle
je pense il sera
en e le ciel de la recherche
médicale
je crois que c'est vraiment à
un enjeu
essentiel
en tout cas dans nos pays pour
100 e
un revenu le l'économique
satisfaisant disons
elkedaoo protesté au sein de
cette recherche médicale
tout ce qui attrait
pour maladies du système
nerveux
et là je vais être un peu plus
l'argent
que ceux que que vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure
c'est à dire les maladies du
cerveau de la moelle épinière
des muscles et des nerfs mais
aussi
la psychiatrie
e et les maladies psychiatriques
constituée au sein
de cette recherche médicale à
un enjeu absolument
considérable
et cet enjeu si vous me
permettez satire à deux choses
d'une part comme vous l'avez dit
au vieillissement de la
population
plus la population vieillit
et plus % à l'euro zeman le
nombre de sujets et qui perdent
la tête
qui ont des difficultés à
marcher augmente
ça c'est le premier fait
et puis joueurs et quelques
chiffres similaires pour bien
montrer l'ampleur du du
problème
mais d'un autre côté et
derrière ça
il ya aussi la chronicité de
ces maladies
c'est-à-dire que même si ces
maladies peuvent débuter plus
tôt dans l'existence
la sclérose en plaques ça
commence à 30 ans
la maladie de parkinson à 55 ou
60 ans
ce sont des maladies
durer toute une vie
et donc c'est la chronicité de
ces maladies
qui fait aussi
qu'elle pose un réel problème
en termes de santé publique
alors vous citez de maladies
notamment la sclérose en
plaques pour lesquelles on est
toujours dans le
dans l'obscurité et dont le
verdict
quelque traitement adjuvant
n'est pas fondamentalement de
donc qu'est-ce qui il laisse
penser que dans ces secteurs-là
% à partir de ce que l'on voit
ou de ce que l'on connaît un
rayon on pourra vivre où on
pourrait vivre et si oui à
quelles conditions
des progrès significatif
je pense que sayer a des
progrès à faire ils sont
déjà notables depuis le
maintenant on va dire une
quinzaine d'années
pour 100 e il ya des traitements
aujourd'hui dans la sclérose en
plaques qui permettent de
réduire
de manière significative
% et le risque de poussée
% au cours de l'évolution de la
maladie
dans la maladie de parkinson
on sait aujourd'hui
avec des techniques très
% et sophistiqué de stimulation
cérébrale
qui d'ailleurs
se sont développées en france
la france est pionnière dans ce
domaine
on sait aussi ont redonné
une autonomie
à des gens qui sont en train de
la perdre
mais ces avancées sont le fruit
de deux choses et ça rejoint un
peu le le thème de priorité
cerveau
c'est à dire d'une recherche
de pointe
il n'y a pas de médecine et de
soins sans recherche
d'un autre côté
d'une collaboration extrêmement
t'importe ans
entre les trois acteurs
principaux
de la santé en dehors des
les pouvoirs publics et des
institutions privées que son
les chercheurs
les médecins
et des patients
comme vous le savez très bien
au cours de ces dernières
années
mais une révolution dans ce
domaine en ce sens ce que
les patients sont devenus les
véritables acteurs
et des acteurs de leur propre
santé
alors vous êtes
totalement très impliquée dans
cela notamment à travers un
institut
de la moelle épinière et du
cerveau qui équipe
de financement totalement
privée
et donc que me vient à l'esprit
de questions parce que leur
même temps que le professeur de
médecine
et très impliqué vous êtes
aussi citoyen et c'est tant sans
doute à ce site à ce titre que
vous avez
participer au cabinet de lionel
jospin
% lorsque j'ai réagi élèves
de cp veiller au maintien de ses
clés magnétiques des questions
de santé
et donc comment voyez-vous
l'évolution des choses parce
que
on est là on a un sentiment
général comme ça
qui peut-être faux mais dede
malgré tout de dégradation des
structures publiques
ou d'insuffisance de moyens
quand on regarde nos
statistiques on voit que de plus
en plus de jeunes chercheurs et
notamment dans le monde dans les
disciplines médicales qui
touche à la recherche
biomédicale
s'expatrier vers les etats-unis
pourquoi
non pas parce qu'ils sont tout
d'un coup
attiré par heure je ne sais
quel goût de de quitter lens à
la la france côte mais parce
que pour l'europe des conditions
de recherche
qui sont de bonnes conditions de
recherche donc le lui envie de
vous faire réagir à cela
comment
comment jugez-vous l'état des
lieux et et puis voilà
c'est un sujet difficile
d'abord
peuple je pense qu'en matière
de recherche
une vraie volonté le politique
qui s'est levé a tenu au cours
de ces dans la dernière année
les quinze dernières années
sous le lac fluence et que des
pouvoirs publics
d
les instituts de recherche
pour cela il est directeur ou
président d'une cernes
du cnrs
véritablement la volonté de
développer
des structures qui soit adapté
à la recherche d les
investissements
significatif
le problème c'est que
finalement il me semble mais là
je parle à titre personnel ma
c'est que ces investissements
sont
été il n'y a pas mais
aujourd'hui il me semble t-il
une politique qui soit une
politique ciblée où on sache
par exemple
une certaine somme est allouée
à la recherche sur les maladies
du système nerveux
d'où l'intérêt de me
semble-t-il de la création
ou de l'idée au moins
de créer de véritables
institute thématiques
c'est l'écart
pour le cancer et je crois que
ça a permis des avancées dans
ce domaine
pour 100 e je pense que les
maladies du système nerveux
cerveau
pour un euro le gilt city
hat-trick
elle serait
aussi
de bonnes candidates ces
maladies
à la création d'un institut
mais pour elle centraliser les
sommes allouées qui sont
significative
je ne dis pas qu'elles sont
insuffisant
et qui permettrait d'avoir une
politique
qui soit une politique je dirais
nationale
régionales et locales
avec une répartition
harmonieuse des thématiques
il faut pas aux recherches être
redondant
maintenant derrière ça
il ya un autre problème qui est
elle lui très lourd
c'est c'est celui de 2 l'axé à
des postes de responsabilité
de jeunes chercheurs qui sont
aujourd'hui
remarquablement formés
ils sont remarquablement formés
en france
ils vont aussi parfaire leur
formation
dans le pays et à l'étranger
aux etats-unis et en
grande-bretagne bon
il acquiert une grande
connaissance ce qui pose
problème c'est qu'on ne les
une organisation
souple
dehecq qui permettent un retour
assez aisée
de ces jeunes
non pas de les faire entrer dans
un système qui est un système
je dirais le totalement audiard
chizé
pour cent et un système qui
soit beaucoup plus horizontale
rouge évalue
les gens
au bout de quelques années
et une petite activité des
actuaires
comme on le fait aux etats-unis
ou en grande-bretagne
des moyens de développer leurs
recherches en fonction des
résultats obtenue faire
confiance
premier premier point
il faut faire confiance aux
jeunes
et ensuite
au bout de quelques années
évaluer leur travail
leur donner les moyens
ça c'est une révolution dans
la pensée mais ce que je veux
dire ce que vos propos l'art
comme ça très tranquille
et près de mon enfance la paix
évident presse et puis en même
temps à chaque phrase recoupé
une révolution en france parce
qu'on sait bien que les
chercheurs le poids de son parti
dans les pires difficultés à
revenir que
tout le système va bloquer à
vrai dire et que rien de cette
horizontalité pour laquelle
vous plaidez n'existe en france
encourage le score
vous alors qu'on rejoint je joue
plus tard le deuxième problème
tel problème de la recherche
universitaire
de la recherche aux soins
ce qui amène à évoquer la
question de l'hôpital
mais que je voudrais juste
pour parler de ce que vous avez
évoqué
le nombre de l'institut du
cerveau et de la moelle
épinière
c'est une fondation
privée reconnue d'utilité
publique
qui a été créée par des
hommes venus d'horizons
totalement différent
mais qui avait
envie de faire quelque chose
arrivé à une certaine
période de leur vie
pour la communauté
le dévouement
et la mort entre pikine qui
permet de financer serait
d'ailleurs il faut dire que les
deux livres
que de regrets que nous avons
cité pl qui sont prétextes à
cet entretien dont que priorité
cerveau chez odile jacob
et pour le cerveau pour les nuls
le chef leur stock fictions
les auteurs ne sont pas
la rémunérait ils sont
nombreux
tous les le produit des droits
d'auteur
un an le montalet à cet
institut
alors le cerveau et de la moelle
épinière beaucoup vont pas
alimenter la recherche
l'institut du cerveau vous avez
parfaitement raison mais c'est
aussi l'illustration de ce que
pourrait être
c'est à dire que cet institut
qui est menée
dans l'esprit de personnalités
que rien ne prédisposait à
sequins se sont engagé
là-dedans je vais pas citer de
noms
ou alors si je suis tout de
suite sur mon bureau
mais cet institut de n'aurait
pas pu non plus voir le jour
à côté de genthod de ligne
cerrone jaunisse de de
pour 100 e de la balle en
caoutchouc noir de gens
d'horizons totalement
différents domaines
il n'y avait pas eu non plus
oui les institutions publiques
lycéenne l'institut du cerveau
il n'aurait pas pu voir le jour
cent la tête de la région
ile-de-france sans l'aide de
paris
la ville de paris sans l'aide du
ministère de la recherche
e donc
c
la réunion
lors de ses efforts et de ces
gens de bonne volonté
la région a joué un rôle
déterminant
qui permet à cet institut
d'accueillir maintenant
des chercheurs
la vocation de cette institution
dette
un instituteur internationale
ouvert sur le monde
accueillant des équipes de haut
niveau
évalués par un conseil
scientifique international
salée plus franco-français
on est dans le rock
et que l'europe en matière de
recherche et même pas suffisant
c'est le monde
c les etats-unis et le japon
bon et cette ce conseil
scientifique évalue des
équipes candidates et les
retient
leur évaluation ce faire au
bout de cinq ans
ils ont déçu
vous restez
pour retourner comme de l eau
dans votre pays d'origine
pour le moment je je je veux
dire 'voilà pas un mode de
fonctionnement
nouveau
et qui est adapté à ce qui est
de la recherche
danse de deux ans dans le
domaine de la médecine
donc c'est possible merci donc
les lions comment il aurait
évidemment mais autre chose à
dire notamment sur le faire pour
mais bon que je renvoie à la
lecture de ce livre qui fait
l'état à la fois de la
recherche et des traitements
sur eux tout ce qui concerne
cerveau priorité cerveau chez
odile jacob le cerveau pour les
bus perché
cerclefinance com
où l'on voit d'ailleurs que la
recherche est évidement pas
abondante
de très haut niveau en deux ans
en france le don que tout cela
est quand même de nature à
donner confiance merci olivier
dit encore
merci à vous
poujol bonjour bonjour merci
d'être là vous êtes de
l'auteur d'un traité
de sociologie qui s'appelle le
destin des générations
qui est paru il ya déjà eu
huit ans et que vous pourrez
éditer
fort opportunément aujourd'hui
au lendemain de manifestations
qui ont pour partie c'était
contre la réforme des retraites
mais pour parties impliquées
des jeunes
et les jeunes sont toujours
entre sujet de de réflexion
d'analysé depuis un certain
temps vous avez mis en
au fond le premier en france un
peu
fausse libération
mais il ya un fossé très
particulier
13la larmes en même temps
m pardon
rappelez vous êtes celui qui
fut le premier avait dit
preuve à l'appui
c'est la première fois au fond
q génération les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui
elles sont victimes
de leur vol de leurs aînés
donc que l'on voit revenir un
petit peu dans le détail de de
de toutes vos thèses mais il
voit là on va peut-être situé
à m
l'ensemble de votre analyse de
cette façon départ
heureux disons que les actions
l'enjeu qui est le mien c'est de
comprendre les transformations
de la société française
je suis un spécialiste
comparaisons internationales je
m'intéresse aux etats-unis
à la chine le japon le chinois
depuis
lieu des années maintenant
% estiment qu'elle fait des
progrès
je suis bien obligé mais au
lieu des marges de progression
chinois sont toujours
indisponibles
quelque soit votre niveau et
vous avez toujours meilleur que
il arrive
quoi qu'il en soit aucune
constance et que la société
française
et une des sociétés de la plus
on est plus profond parmi les
plus profondément
marquer
par le phénomène de fracture
entre les générations
c'est à dire que en france nous
avons une scansion historique
générationnel extrêmement
intéressante
pour résumer très rapidement
aujourd'hui enfants depuis une
dizaine d'années c'est la
première fois en période de
fêtes les
dans l'histoire française que
la génération qui suit va
connaître un sort moins
favorable
que celle que le coco que le
sort de ses propres parents
à l'entrée dans la vie adulte
en fait cette situation est
encore pire parce qu'elles se
prolongent véritablement dans
le temps
en fait cela se construit story
qui est celle-là les
générations nées avant 1920
l'entité dédiée des
générations qui n'ont pas
reconnu en vain
qui n'ont pas encore connu
la pleine expansion de l'état
providence
dans leur jeunesse et ensuite
dans leur vieillesse
ces générations nées avant
920 ce sont les générations
qui seront nombreux
pour qu'ils ont été marqués
par deux guerres mondiales en
particulier par l'afp à la
seconde mi-temps
la génération des verts 1116
sa génération des résistants
vous avez et le
françois-mitterrand vous avez
tout un ensemble
d'autres figures politis
mike
culturel ou du doute d'une autre
nature qui ont
en quelque sorte de marquer
l'histoire
de la deuxième guerre mondiale
et de la reconstruction suite
vous avez une deuxième très
grande génération celle qui
est née
autour de 1 948
mécaniquement
démographiquement
ce sont eux la génération
précédente ses propres enfants
mais vers 1148 dans ces marchés
ont tendance à en faire la
leçon sur l'essentiel c'est de
cela que vous êtes partis au
front parce que la génération
une heure 48 l'année suivante
c'est la génération dite du
baby-boom
pour tiéné avec eux là la
reconstruction et la renaissance
du pays après
la libération
c'est celle qui à 20 ans en 68
celle-ci explose emma 68 2 et
ses celtics à partir des
années 70 e
avance très très vite
m et au fond on s'installe au
poste de commande est ce que
vous décrivez est très bien
fait ensuite comment les choses
se fige
on passe dans les années 70 un
monde très ouvert notamment
sur le marché du travail
un monde d'aujourd'hui carmaux
où le marché du travail
pénaliseront le ser infiniment
plus les jeunes que
toute autre catégorie
et pour les jeunes subissent le
handicap de cette génération
dont vous avez décrit le
parcours
killer qui confondent
continuez à verrouiller le
système à son profit en fait
c'est bien c'est bien de cela
qu'il s'agit c'est de cela qu'il
s'agit
la première édition du destin
des générations en 1998
j'étais blessé le constat
que l'eau avec le ralentissement
économique l'explosion du
chômage de masse
concentré sur les jeunes
elle nous avons une situation on
ne
or il va dire
la classe d'âge intermédiaire
des années 90
conservant son statut s'est
posté ses positions
pendant qu'elle repousse le
chômage sur les nouveaux
entrants
mais si l'histoire des années
80 90 ce qui est très riche et
aujourd'hui
c'est qu'en définitive cette
génération née contours de
248 5
pour qui a réuni 60 jeunes
soixantaine d'années
aujourd'hui
continue
or
depuis deux ans
d'avoir exactement la même
stratégie
ça se voit très bien
l'assemblée nationale à
l'assemblée nationale en 1980
pourquoi un député de plus de
60 ans vous avez pas un député
de moins de 40 ans
ce qui veut dire que les
générations de la résistance
et puis la génération de 68 5
seront représentés au début
des années 80
en quelque sorte à parité
aujourd'hui plus exactement 2007
rwanda réélection
en 2007 pourtant un député de
moins de 40 ans
vous avez une meuf
députés de plus de 60 ans
c'est à dire que la
génération
ddd des jeunes bébé-boumeurs 5
et massivement présentes à
l'assemblée nationale
le sénat a rajeuni
quand on le laisse tomber
nationale vit misérablement
parce que n'y a pas assez de
place
à l'assemblée nationale pour
placer l'ensemble des jeunes
début mars
et ensuite vous avez en deux
heures
générationnel
les jeunes sont ap sens de la
politique ils ne sont pas dans
les syndicats ils ne sont pas le
mouvement
le tout ensemble de lieux de
représentations culturelles de
recherche
ils sont massivement présents
dans la précarité
le chaunois
dans les stages à 320 euros par
mois
pendant que vous avez
effectivement
l'installation la stabilisation
et en quelque sorte de record
l'exploitation des ressources
d'une génération celle du
début des déesses du baby-boom
à la défaveur de la
génération de la fin du
baby-boom
cette génération tx5
des etats-unis qui pour nos
routes la génération qui
exclut l'idée laquelle
celle qui suit le baby-boom
celles nées dans les années 70
qui est extrêmement diplômés
mais ne bénéficient pas de ces
diplômes c'est alors que mais
il est dans une situation
intéressante
la nouvelle génération
massivement de classes moyennes
supérieures du point de vue des
diplômes accumuler
par cette génération née à
partir des années 70 au courant
de la démocratisation est
passée par là voilà gens sont
plus diplômés mais pour eux ce
que vous montrez très bien sait
que les obstacles s'accumulent
sur la route verte la roue leurs
parents albert avancer de façon
assez fulgurante il comprit yeux
dans la constitution da
patrimoine là vous montrer que
les obstacles et sylvain
branché logements pour les
juifs à sa version de travail
avant ces mêmes dans
l'internât l'intérieur de
l'univers du travail nous tenons
très bien que c'est que c'est
une course d'obstacles mais en
même temps
j'ai envie de vous dire c'est un
petit peu la rançon du
la démographie telle qu'elle
est pour le moment m % et parce
que la démographie porta et
l'allongement de la durée de la
vie qui était à l'origine donc
de la réforme des retraites
portas ce que la proportion d
seniors
soit de plus en plus un portant
donc dans l'électorat c'est la
rentrée le début d'un
feuilleton et que nous l'avons
révélé en france où il a
été opéré dans la
comparaison internationale
nous voyons bien que d'autres
pays qui ont une bonne
démocratie c'était des mots de
beaucoup de jeunes
de notamment les pays nordiques
font une place à tout le monde
dans le monde du travail et dans
le monde du logement
et dans toutes les sphères de
valoriser la société
la stratégie française a
consisté à libérer la côte
d'ivoire dans les pays nordiques
pas l'allemagne la marque aux
anneaux a un fils et disons
alain juppé au repos de
l'allemagne est un pays qui est
plus à l'instinct
connor nord de la france sept se
laisser persuader dans certaines
stations fermées l'allemagne
pour pour autant l'allemagne n'a
pas choisi de concentrer le
chômage
à l'entrée dans l'équipe
la stratégie française a
constesté pas consister
à très bien formé nos jeunes
même pas leur donner d'exemple
en face c'est-à-dire que nous
jeunes son classes moyennes
supérieures de pendus du
diplôme et le champion de la
classe se
populaire de bè classe
ouvrière du point de vue des
vrais position dans la société
quand on compare plan sur les
sociétés européennes le
mondial
le constat est sûre
oui espagne grèce
vous avez une génération
deux jeunes moins nombreuses
que nous ce qui en fait la la la
la démographie suicidaire de
l'italie
notamment
je vous avais une île
des jeunes moins nombreux
quinn aucune place dans le
système économique
ni dans le logement
pour les logements sont
inaccessibles
en espagne on appelle cela les
mi-lourds istace
la génération millions euros
deux trentenaires et plus sûre
polyglotte
peuvent très bien formés
titulaires de masters
mais qui n'ont pas de place dans
la société espagnole bami
période
en italie espagne et le rôle
principal on engraisse on parle
de la génération à 6 11 euros
en fait ça
la france n'est pas très loin
de ce risque majeur
évidemment dans les pays du sud
de l'europe où les pays à
façade méditerranéenne
la france en fait partie et les
limites
ce travail gratuit des jeunes
est en fête massivement
financer par le bien-être de
leurs parents de seniors
cette stratégie-là est une
stratégie autour destructrice
qu'elle n'a pas d'avenir
au-delà de 2020
il va pour le le cpu l'avons
vietnam véritablement
explosé
l'allemagne est un pays
intermédiaire on en fait
les jeunes sont moins nombreux
malgré tout ils sont
euros par rapport à leur
formation ils trouvent des
emplois le système
d'apprentissage lune n'est pas
meilleur effet
même si aujourd'hui c'est de
plus en plus déstabilisée
nous n'avons pas en effet à 2
23 ans de génération
sacrifiée qui ont raté leur
entrée dans la vie
les pays nordiques ce sont des
pays ont commencé à travailler
tôt
on fini de travailler dans des
conditions descente jusqu'à 68
ans dans la social-démocratie
même si ce sont des
gouvernements de droite de temps
en temps
vous avez une représentation de
l'om semble
des générations
de 18 22
jusqu'à au moins 68 euros au 1
75 ans
vous avez une parenthèse
générationnel heather une
transmission
du système d'état providence
qui se fait
correctement qui se fait de bien
pour la concurrence avec la
chine c'est la même à
stockholm et ici
mais la capacité des pays
nordiques
à répondre à ce défi
générationnel a été bien
meilleure
malheureusement le constat ces
cures en 98 déjà je note avec
une profonde fracture
intergénérationnel
ce qui est il nie il médite
depuis le 12 ans
la mise-à-jour de la thermique
la permis de constater en france
c'est que la société
française
l'appartement
prix en couleurs ce risque
générationnel qui s'est passé
a indiqué claire approfondissez
cet instant si fier
et maintenant effectivement
c'est la génération des ddd
quasi jeunes cinquantenaire en
tout cas
vieux cadres ingénieurs
qui ont raté leur entrée dans
la vie
à pour le vin 25 ans
au contour des années 80 85
qui sont toujours aujourd'hui
dans la panade
la société française est une
société où il n'existe pas
2 seconde chance
% et parfois même pas première
et ceux qui l'ont raté
dans les années 80 cette
première chance
dans la société française des
années 1980 dans le chômage de
masse concentrer sur les jeunes
- jamais rattrapé ce qui veut
dire qu'en fait nous invente une
société française
extrêmement inquiétante
ou la retraite des
grands-parents
massivement représentés en
politique et dans les
associations familiales
entretiennent 2 une autre
2 bientôt trois générations
sous le même toit
c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement inquiétant
ou pas en fait nous avons eu le
plus de société de rentiers
de rentiers sociaux
où les jeunes générations
bénéficient des retraites
du bien-être des retraites
autre de leurs grands-parents
et bien évidemment nous avons
aussi des 36 états tri monument
le phénomène 9 heures
c'est que la rente explose
la multiplication par trois du
prix du mètre carré à paris
donc comme dans les grandes
villes de région
fait apparaître en fait de
nouvelles familles
nadine d'accumulateurs de
grandes fortunes
qui permettent en fête à leurs
enfants
à eux de travailler pour eux le
droit d'offrir l'éleveur ans
par alain seghi à des
mobilisations de masse pour
défendre cette ce statu quo là
pour défendre ses droits acquis
là pour défendre ses
privilèges de de ce qu'ils sont
m ou qui vont devenir des
anciens qui vont accéder à
l'âge de la retraite et cetera
aux dépens des jeunes donc il
était tailleur tout à fait
surprenant de voir à un moment
ou un autre les jeunes se mêler
à ces manifestations parce que
c'était
parfaitement
les intérêts objectifs comme
le montrait très bien
d'ailleurs été complètement
contradictoire
on a plutôt que trop le temps
d'aller
est plus abondant dans vos
dans vos dans votre livre mais
qui est absolument passionnant
elle est et qui prêterait une
très précis en attendant même
temps
mais on reconnaît à travers le
le destin des générations que
que vous décrivez
on est aussi au coeur de ce
fameux malaise de la classe
moyenne qui qui minent un petit
peu toutes nos sociétés de
l'union européenne
e comme américaine et qui est
que faire
le bel l'afp les perspectives
de s'inverser à dire que les
perspectives d'amélioration
progressive des situations des
uns et des autres
son choix bloquer tout d'un coup
soi-même les gens le craignent
pour leurs enfants je crois
même ans
en danger de relégation le
point très important
effectivement
les jeunes seniors de 2010 5
son aparté la population
la plus prisée du point de vue
de son accumulation patrimonial
de son logement de tous ensemble
d'aspen
plus de ces retraites le social
alors en 2020 la situation va
totalement changer en 2020 les
jeunes seniors seront
ces anciens jeunes de la fin des
années 70 début des années 80
qui ont peiné à accumuler des
annuités qui ont eu des doutes
salaires des carrières
salariale beaucoup plus faible
et qui vont être de nouveau
les jeunes seniors pauvres
que l'on avait vu disparaître
dans les années 70 la pauvreté
c'étaient les seniors
aujourd'hui pour 100 e la
pauvreté ce sont les jeunes
mais en fait ça demain la
pauvreté seront donc de nouveau
et les seniors
le crépuscule des dieux riches
est écrite pour 2017
alors tout cas pour quiconque
veut agir dans la sphère
publique il faut déjà savoir
de quoi il retournait connaître
un petit peu les données
deux des évolutions et de
l'évolution de notre société
donc je renvoie votre livre
louis chauvel le destin des
générations merci d'avoir
été avec nous mais cela prend
du temps et pour celles et ceux
d'entre vous qui souhaitez
retrouver les propos de louis
chauvel comment
les propos du professeur gillian
corps en mouvement
évidemment à tout moment sur
public sénat prendrait fin
ça les airs
cliquez ici